>> GUESS YOU HEARD THIS MORNING,
I TESTED POSITIVE FOR COVID.
I'VE BEEN DOUBLE VACCINATED AND
DOUBLE BOOSTED.
THE SYMPTOMS ARE MILD.
I APPRECIATE YOUR INQUIRY AND
CONCERNS.
I'M DOING WELL.
GETTING A LOT OF WORK DISTRICT
ATTORNEY AND WILL CONTINUE TO
GET IT DONE.
MEANTIME, THANKS FOR YOUR
CONCERN.
KEEP THE FAITH.
IT'S GOING TO BE OKAY.
>> Jesse: PRESIDENT BIDEN SAYING
HE'S DOING WELL AFTER TESTING
POSITIVE FOR COVID.
EXPERIENCING VERY MILD SYMPTOMS
WITH A RUNNY NOSE AND DRY COUGH
AND TAKING PAXLOVID.
HE WILL ISOLATE FOR FIVE DAYS
BUT SAYS HE'S BUSY WORKING.
MAY HAVE JUST NOTICED THAT BIDEN
WAS NOT MASKED UP AND THE WHITE
HOUSE GOT CALLED OUT OVER THAT.
>> LOOK, IN THE VIDEO THAT YOU
SAW, THERE WAS A VIDEOGRAPHY
THAT WAS THERE WITH HIM AND WORE
AN N-95 MASK AND HAD THE SIX
FEET DISTANCE.
THE SAME SITUATION AS WELL WITH
THE PHOTO.
AS YOU SAW IN THE VIDEO, HE WAS
OUTSIDE.
>> Jesse: THE POSITIVE COVID
TEST COMES DAYS AFTER JOE
BIDEN'S MIDDLE EAST TRIP TO
SAUDI ARABIA.
YESTERDAY THE PRESIDENT WAS SEEN
MINGLING WITH A BUNCH OF PEOPLE
BARKING QUESTIONS OVER WHETHER
BIDEN GOT INFECTED.
WHERE, WE DON'T KNOW.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS SHUTTING DOWN
ANY DISCUSSION OF THAT.
>> WHERE WAS HE INFECTED?
I DON'T THINK WE KNOW.
I CERTAINLY DON'T KNOW IF YOU
HAVE ANY THOUGHT PROCESS.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT MATTERS,
RIGHT?
WHAT MATTERS IS WE PREPARED FOR
THIS MOMENT.
>> HOW CAN IT NOT MATTER WE HE
GOT IT?
WITH ALL THE CONTRACT TRACING.
HOW CAN IT NOT MATTER --
>> WHAT IS IMPORTANT NOW IS THAT
HE HAS MILD SYMPTOMS.
HE IS WORKING FROM THE RESIDENCE
ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THAT'S OUR FOCUS.
>> Jesse: WHILE WE WISH THE
PRESIDENT A VERY SPEEDY
RECOVERY, THE WHITE HOUSE SAYS
THERE'S NOTHING TO WORRY ABOUT.
>> YOU GUYS SAW HIM YESTERDAY.
HE WAS IN MASSACHUSETTS.
HE SPOKE FOR 20 MINUTES IN
93-DEGREE WEATHER.
IT WAS HOT.
HE WAS FEELING FINE.
MOST OF US WERE LOOKING FOR
WATER AND TRYING NOT TO PASS
OUT, THE PRESIDENT WAS
DELIVERING REMARKS.
>> Jesse: ALL RIGHT.
SO THE PRESIDENT, GREG, THE LAST
PERSON IN AMERICA TO CATCH
COVID-19.
WE WISH HIM WELL.
WHAT WENT THROUGH YOUR MIND WHEN
YOU HEARD THE NEWS?
>> Greg: I THINK I SPEAK FOR ALL
AMERICANS AND PERHAPS THE WORLD,
PRESIDENT BIDEN PLEASE GET WELL
SOON.
I MEAN, REALLY GET WELL SOON.
DON'T GET SICK.
PLEASE.
I DON'T WANT THE CRAZY CACKLER
IN CHARGE.
I THINK SHE WAS DOING CART
WHEELS TO WORK.
HE LOOKS FINE.
WE KNOW WITH THIS STUFF, THE
SYMPTOMS ARE MILD IN THIS
STRAIN.
REMEMBER, THANK GOD, HIS WIFE IS
A DOCTOR.
SO I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT.
I DO WANT TO DISPEL THAT RUMOR
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW HE GOT IT.
WHEN GAVIN NEWSOME WAS AT THE
WHITE HOUSE, HE WASN'T SNEEZING
ON EVERY DOOR KNOB.
THIS IS THE REASON WHY WE HAVE
TO GO YOUNGER IN 2024, THIS IS A
THEORY.
IT'S A SERIOUS THING.
EVEN THOUGH HE WILL PROBABLY BE
FINE.
BUT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE COVID
AROUND AWHILE.
USED TO BE COLD IN FLU SEASON.
NOW THEY HAVE TO BUILD ANOTHER
AISLE AT WALGREEN'S.
HE'S ALSO 80.
HE HAS MEDICAL CONDITIONS THAT
ARE FAIRLY SERIOUS IN HIS
BACKGROUND.
SO I THINK, YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE
TO LOOK AT THIS AND GO LIKE YOU
KNOW, MAYBE IT'S TIME WE THINK
ABOUT YOUNGER PEOPLE GETTING IN
LIKE GERALDO SAID LAST WEEK.
>> Jesse: PASS THE TORCH.
>> Greg: HAVE TO PASS THE TORCH.
I HOPE HE DIDN'T GET IT FROM A
WINDSHIELD.
>> Jesse: GET CANCER THAT WAY.
>> Greg: I'M SERIOUS, HE CANNOT
GET SICK.
THAT CANNOT HAPPEN.
AMERICA HAS BEEN THROUGH ENOUGH.
WE CAN'T GO THROUGH A KAMALA
HARRIS MOMENT RIGHT NOW.
>> Jeanine: DID YOU SEE HER OUT
TODAY?
SHE WAS HIGH FIVING.
SHE WAS THUMBS UP TODAY.
YOU KNOW, I HAVEN'T SEEN THAT
MUCH ENERGY OUT OF THE WOMAN AS
SHE TOOK OVER AS VICE PRESIDENT.
WE ALL HOPE THAT HE GETS WELL.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU, THE ONE
THING THAT REALLY SENT ME
THROUGH THE CEILING WAS WHEN
KARINE JEAN-PIERRE SAYS, OH, IT
DOESN'T MATTER ABOUT CONTACT
TRACING.
ARE YOU KIDDING?
LAST YEAR EVERY TIME I WENT
THROUGH AN AIRPORT, THEY HAD --
I HAD TO SIGN AN AFFIDAVIT.
YOU COULDN'T LEAVE WITHOUT
FILLING OUT A FORM.
THEN THEY WOULD CALL YOU UP FROM
NEW YORK STATE AND SAY, ARE YOU
LIVING ALONE?
DO YOU LIST WITH SOMEONE?
I SAID IT'S NONE OF YOUR
BUSINESS.
WELL, WE HAVE TO FIND OUT.
I SAID WHY?
IN CASE YOU GET COVID.
I SAID I DON'T HAVE COVID.
WE MAY HAVE TO CONTACT THAT
PERSON.
SO THEY'RE GOING BACK AND FORTH.
MY GOD, WHAT WE ALL WENT
THROUGH.
EVERY TIME I FLEW.
I WAS FLYING EVERY WEEK.
THEY WERE LIKE CONTACT TRACING
IS THE MOST IMPORTANT THING WE
DO.
NOW IT DOESN'T MATTER.
WHO DID HE GET IT FROM?
>> Jesse: WE DON'T KNOW IF IT'S
FROM THE SAUDIS OR THE PEOPLE IN
MASSACHUSETTS.
WE'RE JUST GETTING WORD FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE, THEY'RE SAYING THAT
THE VICE PRESIDENT WAS A CLOSE
CONTACT OF THE PRESIDENT BUT
SHE'S NOT CHANGING HER SCHEDULE
AT ALL.
JESSICA?
>> MAYBE THIS IS JUST THE BRAVE
NEW WORLD.
WE SHOULD BE ADAPTING TO IT.
I UNDERSTAND IT FEELS INADEQUATE
TO HAVE THE PRESS SECRETARY THIS
DOESN'T MATTER.
YOU SHOULD HAVE A BETTER WORDED
RESPONSE.
THE ANSWER IS THIS IS THE NEW
NORMAL.
THE PRESIDENT IS 79.
THESE ARE THIS PEOPLE THAT HAVE
A HARD TIME WITH COVID.
THE VICE PRESIDENT I DID NOT
NOTICE ANY PEP IN HER STEP.
HER SMILING DOESN'T --
>> Jeanine: SHE LAUGHS AT
EVERYTHING.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
>> WE'VE ALL BEEN VACCINATED AND
BOOSTED.
I HAD MY SECOND BOOSTER.
I HAVE HAD COVID.
I BELIEVE DOUBLE VACCINATED AND
BOOSTED.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO REASSESS
HOW SOCIETY WORKS.
IF CONTACT TRACING IS NO LONGER
SOMETHING THAT IS WORTH WHILE
BECAUSE WHEN YOU GO TO AN EVENT
NOW, IT'S NOT LIKE YOU'RE AROUND
FIVE TO SEVEN PEOPLE.
YOU CAN GO TO WEDDINGS WITH 200,
300 PEOPLE.
YOU TRAVEL AROUND THE WORLD,
MEET WITH HEADS OF STATED.
SAY WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO MOVE
PAST CONTRACT TRACING AS A
COUNTRY.
THIS IS NOT GOING TO SERVE A
PURPOSE ANYMORE.
BE HONEST ABOUT THAT.
THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO SEE FROM
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS.
YOU KNOW WHAT COVID IS.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE TREATMENT IS.
WHAT IS THE NEW NORMAL IN
PROCEDURES.
>> Jesse: WHAT IF HE HAS LONG
COVID AND LOSES HIS SENSE OF
SMELL AND HE CAN'T START
SNIFFING PEOPLE?
I MEAN, THAT'S --
>> FIRST OF ALL, I LEARNED A NEW
WORD, GREG.
>> Greg: WHAT IS IT?
>> IT'S A RHINORRHEA.
>> Greg: IT'S A RUNNY NOSE.
LIZ CHENEY HAS IT ALL THE TIME.
>> YEAH, THE COVID COORDINATOR
TODAY SAID THE PRESIDENT HAS A
MILD ILLNESS.
THAT IS TRUE.
IT'S BEEN THAT WAY FOR COVID FOR
A VERY, VERY LONG TIME.
SINCE THE BEGINNING COVID HAS
BEEN MILD FOR THE VAST MAJORITY
OF PEOPLE, 98% OF THE PEOPLE.
IT'S GOOD WE'RE NOT PANICKING
AND TIME TO MOVE ON.
IT'S IRONIC THE PRESIDENT
CAMPAIGNON SHUTTING DOWN THE
VIRUS AND HERE WE ARE WITH HIM
TESTING POSITIVE.
ALSO TODAY DURING THE WHITE
HOUSE BRIEFING, IT WAS ABSURD TO
WATCH THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY ANSWER QUESTIONS
SECONDHAND AND NOT ALLOW THE
WHITE HOUSE PHYSICIAN TO ANSWER
THE QUESTIONS DIRECTLY.
THEY KEPT ARGUING IT WASN'T
TELEPHONED, THEY KNEW WHAT WAS
HAPPENING.
THEY DIDN'T SEE THE PRESIDENT
BECAUSE THEY CALLED THE
PRESIDENT INSTEAD OF BEING IN
THE ROOM WITH HIM.
THAT WOULDN'T HAVE FLOWN UNDER
TRUMP.
THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN ACCUSED OF
HIDING SOMETHING.
THEY SHOULD MAKE THE WHITE HOUSE
PHYSICIAN AVAILABLE ESPECIALLY
SINCE HE'S PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
PERSONAL PHYSICIAN AS WELL AND
YOU'D HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS TO
THE QUESTION.
IT'S INTERESTING TO SEE THE
WHITE HOUSE AND THE PRESIDENT
SAYING THANK YOU FOR THE
VACCINES, I'M DOUBLE VACCINATED,
DOUBLE BOOSTED.
THAT'S WHY MY SYMPTOMS ARE MILD
AND YOU NEED TO TAKE CREDIT FOR
OPERATION WARP SPEED, WHICH IS
PRESIDENT TRUMP THAT PUT IN
PLACE AND JOE BIDEN -- CANDIDATE
BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS THAT
QUESTIONED THE EFFICACY OF THE
VACCINES AT THE BEGINNING THAT
NOW HE'S THANKING FOR HAVING HIM
FEEL BETTER TODAY.
>> IF THEY WEREN'T GOING TO TAKE
IT --
>> YES, HE DID.
>> Jeanine: THEY WEREN'T GOING
TO TAKE IT --
>> WE'RE HAPPY THE PRESIDENT IS
DOING WELL.
YOU KNOW --
>> Greg: I NEED A BOOSTER TO SEE
OVER THE DASHBOARD.
>> Jesse: IS THAT IT?
YOU WANT TO SAY SOMETHING ELSE?
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW.
DO I WANT TO GET IN TROUBLE?
I HAVE TO FLY SOMEWHERE.
I REITERATE THAT WE HOPE -- WE
PRAY THAT HE GETS WELL FOR THE
SAKE OF THE COUNTRY AND THE